são duas imagens que me chocam muito
esse aqui é o brasil é o que a comida o
que alimenta o que é ingrediente o que é
cozinhar o que é esse ato que a gente
faz o que o clima o que abelha o que o
tempo o que tudo isso tem a ver com o
alimento que a gente coloca na nossa
mesa todos os dias o que o lixo tem a
ver o que a mudança climática o que tem
a ver com pequenas ações que tem a ver o
plástico o vidro que tudo isso tem a ver
com o face com arroz o feijão bife o ovo
que eu tenho na minha casa
nada a ver tem tudo a ver muito dessas
coisas são causadas pela gente quase
tudo isso que tem a ver a doença o que
tem a ver a gripe o que tem haver limite
o que tem a ver cansa com tudo isso é o
que você põe na sua boca é tudo que você
escolhe são escolhas
ninguém coloca nada na sua boca você
escolhe o que você come você muita gente
escolhe pela criança
muita gente se culpa na quando a gente
viaja é principalmente mães é que
começar a trabalhar a gente se culpa a
gente compra bala pirulito de chocolate
aí sim a culpa sua aí sim você colocar
dentro da da boca do seu filho você dá
daí sim você também está causando um
problema bom
o que acontece com o mercado o que
acontece com a tv o que acontece com a
indústria porque a gente compra né
quando os alimentos você consome na sua
casa vem direto da horta enquanto os
alimentos você consome são processados e
industrializados e embalados
enquanto os alimentos que você compra em
balado que está escrito som nome seja
suco que tem dentro dessa embalagem
dessa caixinha
a gente faz um suco de manga fresca em
casa com uma manga deixou fora da
geladeira certo quanto tempo isso vai
durar um dia como um suco
uma caixinha está dentro do mercado e
dura seis meses 32 dentro como ele pode
durar tudo isso com a nossa preguiça de
você compra uma manga chegar em casa foi
um suco
há um problema com isso não a gente
criou os problemas
tudo porque o tempo tempo esse é o nosso
maior obstáculo e tudo isso acontece a
não tenho tempo por um segundo você pode
ser prata na olimpíada
um segundo e o segundo lugar sempre
nunca é bom e é o tempo de novo a gente
volta o tempo esse tempo ele tem que
estar indo até às 24 horas
o alimentar tem que ter calma tem que
ter prazer
ninguém com ninguém pode cozinhar por
trabalho a partir do momento que você
está cozinhando por trabalho para ganhar
dinheiro tá errado tá tudo errado você
precisa cozinhar para mudar pra mudar
uma nação para mudar uma história para
mudar uma cidade uma comunidade ou até
para mudar dentro da sua casa quatro
pessoas seis duas você e seu marido
é assim que a gente muda nós somos
exemplos exemplo dentro da minha casa ou
seja vocês dentro da casa de vocês nós
somos exemplo para uma criança
somos exemplo dentro da nossa empresa
somos exemplos dentro do trabalho de
você é você ver o teu lanche pode
esperar o lanche que você leva dentro da
empresa vai inspirar o colega ao lado em
foi quando é realmente eu comecei a
pensar no que eu servia e o que é o
papel do restaurante o que 20 lugares
dentro de um restaurante e toda a equipe
que eu tenho pode mudar
como a gente pode mudar em 2015
universidade de cambridge fez uma
pesquisa é nos países que mais têm
alimentos saudáveis e as crianças são
mais saudáveis ea família os adultos 10
dos países mais saudáveis nove estão na
áfrica porque é tão na áfrica porque ela
não tem indústria
ainda se não entra porque são países é
que não são tão afortunados
então é esses lugares não têm televisão
não tem iphone e telefones celulares
por que a gente é eu estava num jantar
há tempos atrás e tinha uma família de
quatro pessoas
as duas crianças estavam com o ipad a
mãe o pai no celular
durante uma hora e meia dentro do
restaurante eles não trocaram uma
palavra
o garçom apenas deixou o prato e aquela
comida foi pra quê
só pra se nutre tô pagando vamos comer
isso acontece o que gera tudo isso gera
obesidade gera doenças em geral de
comunicação gera muita coisa de casa a
comida pode gerar tanto o transtorno que
a gente nem imagina porque a gente nunca
pensou que nunca se colocou naquele
momento e é muito importante a gente
entender o que o alimento pode fazer uma
casa ele pode unir porque a gente come a
gente celebra a gente festeja a gente
viaja alimenta cultura cultura porque a
gente usa o nome de estado bahia o que
vem na cabeça acarajé e moqueca comida é
cultura e cultura porque porque a gente
vai cozinhar a história da minha avó a
comida relembra amor ela traz felicidade
tem coisa melhor que você chega em casa
e sentir o cheiro de cebola e alho
queimando não porque você sabe que
alguém está esperando alguém está
esperando uma comida né você não vai ter
que abrir uma lata e colocar ali dentro
às vezes me choca imagens como
supermercado
a quantidade que a gente toca quantidade
de latas que a gente tem em casa
a quantidade de produtos que a gente
compra a gente não usa e você continua
em um supermercado colocando mais coisa
dentro da data do seu estoque né
tem coisas a gente toca como se o mundo
fosse acabar nós compramos os carrinhos
de mercado uma família básica brasileira
de quatro pessoas
eu vou no supermercado porque o
supermercado não tem classe não tem
classe social dentro do supermercado
a gente encontra todo mundo igual dentro
do supermercado todos somos iguais e os
carrinhos são enormes
se um engradado cd de refrigerante com
gás são engradados de de produtos
congelados são coisas que as pessoas vão
colocando dentro daquele aquele carrinho
para estocar porquê porque a gente não
pode cozinhar porque a gente não pode
pegar a farinha água e fermento e abrir
um rolo uma massa de pizza seja ela boa
ou não o problema é você passar isso pra
frente
quantas pessoas você se reúne batendo um
bolo dentro de casa
um bolo você vai misturar não importa no
liquidificador você vai fazer na mão
você tem batedeira não tem
quantas pessoas vão está envolta na
cozinha quando as pessoas ficam em volta
da cozinha e o ato de você tocar fazendo
em ok que a batata e farinha
quantas pessoas na casa todo mundo vai
colocar a mão para fazer isso
quantas pessoas você vai reunir quantas
mãos a gente vai reunir o quanto a
história vai ter atrás dessa mesa e
atrás desse prato é tão simples tão
fácil de fazer
a gente precisa voltar a cozinhar a
gente precisa respeitar o alimento a
gente precisa respeitar o tempo porque a
gente precisa respeitar o tempo porque
quando a gente sai para no mercado com
uma receita você que é aquele produto
você vai cozinhar morango você precisa
do morango precisa
não você não precisa de morango você
precisa de criatividade porque se o
nosso produtor produz um morango inteiro
o que acontece acontece problemas no
clima no solo na economia
na falta de produto o que a falta de
produto
falta de produto é a gente falar há
milhares de anos atrás nós tínhamos mas
de olhos cento e poucas quais tipos de
alfaces
hoje nós temos pouquíssimas alfaces e
todas iguais com uma foto com você pra
você como é que todas as sementes a
gente coloca aquele momento e ela cresce
todos iguais como um mar de alface mar
de broccoli mar de cor que pode isso eu
não sei na minha horta em casa não
acontece isso um sinal de vocês
eu quanto a salsinha uma creche assim
outra sim o traçado e cada uma de um
jeito
então a gente precisa começar a abrir os
olhos porque que nós temos que ter
alface embalada no plástico e nos opor
porque o biscoito a cra que a gente
compra vem um pacote com multa e
pacotinho dentro porque a gente precisa
disso porque quer separar lixo né
que é isso que o plástico faz o que
acontece
a gente precisa começar a mudar a gente
precisa começar a olhar a gente precisa
mudar a gente precisa mudar a cidade à
comunidade e todos os lugares onde a
gente frequenta pra mim
cozinhar é uma expressão de amor é
conhecimento é técnica é autenticidade é
respeito respeito ao produto ao
cozinheiro a meu avental à minha família
à minha comunidade e as pessoas que
estão ao meu redor
minha relação com os vegetais é muito
profunda tem uma relação muito grande
com a terra
meu pai me ensinou que a terra é de onde
vem o alimento que eu tenho que dar
muito valor ao produtor a pessoa que
semeou que plantou e que chegou na minha
mesa e que aquilo demorou muito tempo
para chegar até 6 meses ela passou por
muitos lugares
ela passou pelo cara que transportou
pelo gás que ele usou ele chegou dentro
do mercado até chegar dentro da minha
casa e isso tudo teve um tempo então eu
preciso respeitar isso
a minha avó me ensinou a respeitar as
mãos a respeitar o tempo que o
cozinheiro teve ali há horário que ele
chegou a lavagem que ele teve no produto
aquela água naquela água que ele
utilizou a gente não sabe mas um quilo
de carne são 18 mil litros de água para
um quilo de carne está dentro da nossa
mesa pra todos os dias ali e às vezes a
gente joga fora a gente joga pra não tá
bom
um ficou bom esse prato que eu fiz não é
porque não ficou bom
não existe gente produto ruim o produto
bom existe a sua escolha a maneira que
você vai escolher até você chegar a
receita final errar pra mim não existe
eu não posso errar e eu sempre falo
eu não vim ao mundo a passeio a gente
tem que vir pra mudar para deixar um
legado para passar informações e idéias
e criar novas formas de a gente fazer
uma sociedade melhor
acredito que podemos mudar a alimentação
de uma nação através de ações dentro de
nossas casas ações usando a terra como
exemplo é da terra que traz muito
benefício e muitas coisas para dentro da
nossa casa
luto pelo alimento de do alimento de de
qualidade luta pela diversidade e pela
sustentabilidade luto pelos pequenos
produtores nosso estado
luto pela informação e pela educação não
basta simplesmente você comprar você
pode transformar seja na feira você
trocar uma receita seja você ensina o
método uma forma de utilizam tal de
cenoura utilizar um talo de brócolis
seja ensinar a fazer uma compostagem
seja você mudar a cabeça informações de
pessoas
a gente precisa e tá na hora de a gente
fazer essa mudança
agora é o momento e o brasil precisa ser
exemplo disso
minha comida é uma forma de defender a
minha filosofia e contar a minha
história a história da minha família a
história de quem me trouxe ao mundo
eu cozinho para mudar o tempo para mudar
o humor das pessoas para mudar a relação
com as crianças para mudar as pessoas
que estão ao meu lado para mudar a saúde
para mudar a minha comunidade para mudar
a minha cidade para mudar o meu país e
para mudar o mundo mas antes de tudo eu
cozinho por mim mesma porque eu tenho
certeza que não só eu eu coloquei as
sementes na cabeça de todos vocês aqui
hoje e agora eu jogo bom para vocês que
eu vocês usam água para regar e plantar
sementes em outros lugares ou essa
semente simplesmente foi colocada aqui e
acabamos aqui hoje
muito obrigada
[Aplausos]